Y.
Las computadoras cuánticas son muy sensibles al ruido,
perturbaciones que causan errores
en sus cálculos, pero una investigación muestra
las computadoras ruidosas de IBM igualando métodos clásicos exactos
y verificando los regímenes, superando métodos clásicos sofisticados
de aproximación en regímenes tanto verificables
como difícilmente verificables.
para un experimento de simulación desafiante.
¿Cómo lo logran? Usan una técnica especial
para lidiar con el ruido
en los sistemas cuánticos: se llama mitigación de errores.
Con la técnica de mitigación de errores
usada en este experimento, ejecutamos nuestros cálculos
y aumentamos el ruido lentamente.
Luego extrapolamos de vuelta a la resolución sin ruido.
Este trabajo nos acerca un paso más a la computación cuántica útil
nosotros